and do you think we have we're facing a
crisis of masculinity at the moment
men going not really certain what their
role is in the world
no i think that's bollocks
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
a terrific guest today is a journalist
and author of stand by your manhood
peter lloyd welcome to trigonometry hi
thanks for having me it's great to have
you
listen for anyone who hasn't seen the
peter lloyd destroys feminist
videos that populate that make up 80
of youtube traffic in the world uh tell
everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that brings
you inexorably here okay so as you said
i'm a journalist and
author of standby oman yes this
brilliant book here which
i can i can say that jordan peterson
actually has a copy of
oh wow so if that isn't like being
blessed by the pope i don't know what is
um and of course i'm responsible for the
sticks and stones meme
which has got me many pints in pubs over
the years which is fantastic
and uh i'm now in the process of writing
another book
on a similar topic and continuing to try
and
defend men from this ongoing culture war
which we find
ourselves embroiled in and why do we
need defending
because nobody else is doing it and
because the attacks are getting
more vitriolic more aggressive uh more
incendiary than ever
and i i just think it's you know if we
continue down this road
for much longer it's going to be a
pretty depressing state of affairs when
we get there
and we always hear this term being used
a culture war and some people will talk
about it and say you know
some people even say that it doesn't
exist to you what do you think
what does it mean the term the culture
war
well i mean i think you don't have to
look very far for the evidence
um only this week the the un the united
nations said that kovid 19 was proof
of patriarchy and that society needed to
be
totally deconstructed and rebuilt in
this feminist
vision which i'm sure we cannot all
agree would be pretty horrendous
uh what else happened we've had even
though i mean men suffer from covert
significantly more oh yeah worse than
women forget that men have been the
highest fatality group
of covert 19 that's irrelevant you know
when the asteroid hits earth it's always
women who are most
affected um uh we've had the
american psychological association
publishing formal guidelines saying that
masculinity
is dysfunctional and that doctors should
treat male patients accordingly which is
outrageous we've also had gillette
telling
their customer base and half the
population that they are
probably aggressive and abusive and
only recently even the dalai lama chimed
in on this he said did he
didn't he get cancelled i thought that
to me that was pete twitter when i went
on twitter once it was like
canceled dalai lama he said something
about how europe should be for europeans
or something like that
uh he did but then i think maybe he was
keen to redeem himself with the woke
because he's the best man yeah well it's
easy to throw blokes under the bus yeah
so uh he said that um he hoped that
there were more women elected to
positions of power
because they are superior at leading
countries
all right so i mean if that is spiritual
enlightenment for you then we're all
[ __ ]
right and maybe he was just trying to
get lied well maybe he wasn't going to
get laid i mean a lot of men do that
right yeah
they play that card to get laid but um
as i always say you might get laid in
the short term but you'll get shafted
in the long term don't do it so i guess
what you're really talking about when
you talk about the culture war and
and some of the examples that you give
is the the mainstream narrative has been
for quite some time
that women are disadvantaged oppressed
etc
would you would you disagree with that i
mean we obviously saw with
the metoo movement which went quite far
let's be honest i'm sure we'll get into
that but it did expose a lot of
wrongdoing
by a lot of powerful men and that sort
of behavior
it exists right um you know there was
the perpetual talk of the gender pay gap
we've had plenty of guests
on to talk about you know how that's
misunderstood and whatever
but there is a sort of perception that
women are sort of more affected by
disadvantage in society and i think we
all would know women who who have been
affected by some of those things so uh
are you put you're pushing back against
that narrative because you feel no one
else is
yeah i mean a couple of other people are
but certainly when i started there
weren't many people doing it
and i felt really compelled to do
something and say something because
a i'm a man and so i've got a vested
interest in
you know our future survival as a
species and also because
i'm a journalist and it's my duty to
kind of report the truth and to speak
the truth
even if it's unpopular and readers don't
necessarily want to hear it
and that's especially true if the
establishment
doesn't want to hear it and as any
journalist would know
uh you know journalism is very very much
feminist friendly there are a lot of
feminist columnists out there
a lot of editors are kind of you know
imbued with that narrative that women
are oppressed
and and need help and that men are
oppressors that need to
you know to always be taken down a peg
or two and
uh so would you uh
what is your main issue of disagreement
with
that narrative why do you not think that
that's true
i probably don't think it's true either
but i'm curious to right to get you to
explain it so that we can get you
canceled instead of me
well you know i mean i can have all the
beliefs that i have and truly believe in
them but
also recognize that you know women don't
have perfect lives
they will experience some encounters of
sexism and harassment along the way and
of course that's unfortunate and i'd
rather it didn't happen
but it's also real life men will also
face examples of discrimination and
harassment
and there will be things that happen to
them that are unfortunate and then i
wish didn't happen
what i have a problem with is that the
narrative that's
so incredibly mainstream and so powerful
and is now such a massive cash cow
is that it doesn't ever mention any of
the issues that face men so it's not
really about equality
what it's really about is pushing
forward this agenda
that's very feminist friendly that's
promoting and safeguarding women all the
time
frequently at the expense of men and if
we continue to do that we're going to
end up with a male
underclass who either check out of
society metaphorically
or literally but peter don't you think
as well that
you know you say men get harassed and of
course we do but it's in
far less than the way women do you know
it's very rare for a man to get shouted
out when walking down the streets
and practically every woman i talk to
says that when it gets dark they're
walking by themselves they put their key
in between their fingers and you know so
if something happens they can hit and
run
you know walking down a dark alley they
would never do
we do it as a matter of course don't you
think that there's a
they've got a reason to be grumbling do
you not just nearly get mugged like a
week ago
yeah but i thought him off because my
point has been made and i haven't even
needed to say
yeah but yeah but i got i fought him off
because i'm a legend so
you know that's why when you're an alpha
mate now shut up and answer the question
so look being male and being female
it's a complicated mix of benefits and
burdens for both sides
no gender has it all good all the time
and no gender has it all bad all the
time despite
what a lot of columnists and feminists
would have you believe
uh you know if men are oppressors then
they must be
the worst oppressors in history we pay
the most taxes we get the least state
support we're the most likely to be
violently attacked we're the most likely
to be unemployed
jailed denied access to our children
shafted in a divorce
and on top of all that we have to play
longer matches at wimbledon for the same
money
it's a raw deal it's a raw deal and of
course
we die sooner but none of those things
are addressed it's just
you know fragile masculinity if you try
and address any of
those issues and for all all the
allegations that feminism is interested
in true equity
he never addressed these issues well
i mean there's so many things to pick up
on that let's start with feminism
because it's a term that
actually has so many meanings that it's
it's important to define so if we talk
about feminism as
the belief that men and women are equal
and should be treated equally
he's a russian can you just see the look
of disgust on his face as he said those
words
i imagine that you and i would both be
feminists if that was the definition of
feminism right right i think everybody
would be afraid
i'm just ignoring your stupid jokes
and because i ignored it you look even
more stupid right there sorry francis
what you cancelled
for the red
uh and you nearly got mugged yeah so uh
but anyway
uh so we on that definition we would all
be feminists
right so when when you were talking
about feminism what is it that you're
talking about
it's actually hard to define i mean i'm
not truly sure what
feminism is about anymore it's certainly
not about women's liberation in the
middle east
it's certainly not about uh you know the
girls in rotherham who were victims of
rape gangs and it's certainly not in the
interests of women who
choose not to have a career and want to
raise children
and be a housewife so i'm not really
sure what feminism
is about anymore but i think probably
the most accurate definition is to say
it's not about equality it's trade
unionism for women
and usually a certain type of woman
usually a middle-class
professional woman and why do you think
that feminism
you've you've you've touched some very
salient points you know for instance the
horrors of the grooming gangs
when we had ella hill and she talked i
think was about half a million girls
who've been abused or you know the way
women are being oppressed in places like
the middle east
why don't they address these particular
issues
even though these are very important
issues regarding women well
what a terrific question that is i mean
i think we've all been asking that
question of feminists for a long time
and i think
the answer is a it's a thorny issue
and b it requires effort and it wouldn't
give them
any immediate gain in their very nice
lives in london or wherever in the
country they choose to live
and so they just don't focus on it all
they're interested in is
you know these kind of mythical pay gap
issues
or you know i mean recently i mean only
today i read a story about a woman who's
who's taking legal action against the
only male-only club
in london called the garrick which is
very historic it's a place lawrence
olivier used to hang out in
it's a safe space you know it's just a
nice space forgot you know for men
together
and i'm happy with that i'm happy for
women to have women only clubs
but you know she's launching this legal
campaign against the garrick
but she's totally fine with all the
women only clubs that exclude men so
you know they seem to be filling their
minds with all this subterfuge and all
these
inconsequential matters which either
aren't real or aren't important
and then they don't have time to focus
on the really important things which
which is difficult and requires complex
thought and
having to have consistent principles
that's the tricky bit and i always say
that
to feminists both male and female i say
this to feminists is that
the trick is you've got to apply your
principles consistently
so you know and that's the hard bit
there's a lot of inconsistency flying
around definitely
let's talk about men though because i
think that what you said which is meant
checking out
is a big part of why this issue concerns
me and concerns us because uh
i think what you're talking about
broadly speaking is quite accurate which
is
there's a sort of unspoken or sometimes
spoken feeling that
there's something wrong with men men by
definition are bad
masculine qualities that traditionally
would be considered virtues and now
vices
etc and we have seen this sort of
uh particularly fueled by the internet
and the ability of people with sort of
very
peculiar ways of thinking to band
together and to reinforce each other's
whatever
um the sort of in-cell and all of this
sort of stuff
and i don't know whether you feel i feel
all of that is deeply unhealthy
from for men and for women for there to
be this sort of
uh you know pressure on men and then
they check out and then you end up in
this really weird place
between men and women is that your take
on it as well or do you have a sort of
different perspective
no i agree i don't think it's
masculinity that's toxic i think it's
the narrative
about masculinity that's toxic we you
know we hear all the time
that we shouldn't body shame people or
we shouldn't [ __ ] shame people
we shouldn't make people feel bad
because if you do that then it might
damage their mental health and who knows
what that will lead to
and yet despite being told that
the exact opposite is true when men are
spoken about
they're told that they're defective
they're deficient that they should be
more like women
that they're emotionally illiterate you
know they are told that they are
potential abusers in waiting
and really that there's there's surplus
of requirements we're constantly told
the future is female messages like this
and i
it doesn't take a rocket scientist to
work out that after a while
that builds up and it's cumulative and
if you are i mean i'm lucky i've never
been
clinically depressed but if i were
depressed or if i was feeling
disenfranchised
that narrative over a relatively
relatively short period of time could
easily push someone
over the edge or push someone at least
to the point of checking out of society
and do you think we have we're facing a
crisis of masculinity at the moment
men going not really certain what their
role is in the world
no i think that's bollocks finally
another episode where you can get out
and not even buy me peter keep going
carry on if i can be frank i think it's
bollocks yeah
i i think uh you know if masculinity
is in a state of flux because of perhaps
where we are in the states of the world
then you know what so is femininity men
are in no more a state of crisis
than women are um and so i think really
the reality is that we need to stop
focusing on men at being a fault and
holding
womanhood as the gold standard because
it's just not true
and you mentioned male mental health
obviously if anyone is watching this and
are affected by as a man you need to man
up
but i make the joke deliberately to make
the point that
i mean i think we definitely do treat
men and women differently
um do you but do you think i mean i feel
with mental
men male mental health i thought you're
going to say mental men then
mental men mental health same thing
enough about you
yes same thing but um i almost feel like
we're starting to move
too far now where it's like oh i mean
one of the
important qualities for men and the
three of us will know this
if you want to do anything in life you
do need a dose of sort of
get on with it attitude right so
teaching men to be more like women and
talking about their feelings all the
time i'm not sure that's helpful to
young men
it's totally not helpful men and women
process
emotions and their feelings and their
life experiences in different ways
all the studies show that men are
typically more emotionally flat
throughout whatever they're going
through whereas women tend to be more up
and down
and that's fine it's what i was saying
earlier is that we treat
the female experience the female way of
doing things as the gold standard and
how men should behave
and it just doesn't translate and i i
really get
frustrated with this narrative and you
see it all the time whenever there's
talk about male suicide or male mental
health it's
the implication is always that the men
themselves are to blame
rather than the really grotesque culture
in which they're forced to live
so it's you know oh this man's depressed
and he's suicidal
that's because he's not able to talk
about his feelings and he's not able to
cry
if he opened up more he'd feel much
better and he wouldn't be such a burden
on society
and you think maybe that isn't the
problem maybe the problem is what made
him to feel suicidal in the first place
which
might just be the fact that who knows
he's been divorced and he's not allowed
to see his children
or that he's lost his job after all men
are the majority of the unemployed in
this country
or maybe it's the fact that he's just
sick of being told that
he's unwelcome in modern britain and do
you think part of the problem as well is
that we expect
and we've touched on it as well we
expect men and women to be exactly the
same that there's no difference between
men and women
when we both know and everyone knows
that there is
yet somehow there's this narrative being
propagated it's like there should be no
difference between the sexes whatsoever
right but what always makes me laugh is
that we are told
exactly that there are no differences
between the sexes there is no such thing
as a male and female brain
even though we know that's not true yes
there's lots of overlap but there are
differences
between the male and female brain so
we're told that they're exactly the same
that gender is a social construct until
it benefits women
and then and then we hear ah see females
are better leaders
because they're more compassionate and
they're not compassionate so you know or
women are just more women advance better
at a younger age girls grow up and
mature better than boys because
that's just how their wife i think
that's true yeah no i think it's true
but it's funny that we say oh there are
no differences
between the genders until it benefits
yeah
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit
uh i know that when you go on holiday
sometimes you don't speak the language
it can feel really awkward
a little bit like francis talking to a
woman do you want to learn another
language
now i don't for obvious reasons but if
you do
then babel is quite simply one of the
finest apps to use to achieve your goal
it is it's got amazing simple to use
interface they've got daily 10 to 15
minute lessons that you can do
that have been proven effective in many
studies as a great way to learn one of
14
languages that they offer so it doesn't
matter if you've got struggle with
language
for a variety of different reasons maybe
you find it tough or maybe you're just
english
right now babel is offering trigonometry
fans
six months completely free all you've
got to do is head over there get the six
month subscription
and use our special code which is of
course trigger go to babble
dot co dot uk play
and use the promo code trigger on your
six month subscription
that's b a b b e l dot co dot uk
forward slash play and use the code
trigger
and we're not going to explain how to
spell the word trigger because that
would be patronizing
[Music]
absolutely the thing that worries me i'm
really glad we have you on the show
because i think this is a really
important conversation
but the thing that worries me at the
back of my head is
i i don't want men and women to be in
this sort of conflict the battle of the
sexes is the most [ __ ] thing i've
ever heard
right too much fraternizing with the
enemy right right like
you i men and women need each other
it's always been that way it will always
be that way that's the way it is right
so for for everybody to do this sort of
let's do a tally of the of what men
suffer from
and let's do a tally of what women
suffer from and let's compare notes and
go no no we are more oppressed no we are
more oppressed
right that is the most counterproductive
and stupid thing i've ever [ __ ] heard
right and yet here we are sort of doing
it right
so how do we have a more healthy
conversation about these issues
well i think a lot of the responsibility
lies with the
the sisterhood really i think they need
to moderate themselves and we were
talking earlier about the labour party
weren't we and
they've kind of moderated slightly now
kiyostama is
is the leader of the party and i think
maybe it will take
somebody or some group of people to
you know to kind of modulate the message
that comes out of the sisterhood
um but i also think that it's it's
different
for men because or at least i feel
like my motivation in doing this
is not to come across as the victim
because i don't really think
i think men can be disadvantaged and
sometimes systematically but i don't
really think of us as victims
i don't really think of women as victims
either
but you know i feel like my motivation
is good and men discussing this
would also have good motivation because
they're defending something that's being
attacked
rather than attacking someone else i
think that's the difference between how
men and women approach
this debate but i totally agree that you
know
the genders of you know men and women
are beginning younger the genders
right and we are designed to
you know couple up and procreate and all
those other things and
life would be pretty boring if there was
only one gender in the world
unfortunately there's 27
64 actually you bigger there's been one
invented since we started this interview
but
one thing that i really wanted to talk
to you about is fathers
because there's this idea now that you
know
that single mum can bring up her kids
and of course she can all the rest of it
but fathers are a little bit redundant
we don't need dads we don't need them
do you agree with that well i agree that
that's
that's the message that's put out there
yeah and it's frequently believed but
i think that all the evidence points to
the contrary if you look at all the data
on this children who grow up in families
without fathers
frequently more disadvantaged they
frequently fail
more academically professionally or
generally in life
and you know that lack of a role model
can sometimes lead to things like you
know gang culture
so i think it's a myth
i think people are deluding themselves
if they believe that you can have a
family
and that if the absence of a father
isn't going to make a big difference i
mean if
if my father who i love daily and i'm
very close to him very lucky
you know if he died god forbid
people would say i'm so sorry for your
loss what a huge hole
in your life you would have
and yet if i never had him from the
start
people would never even think that they
wouldn't think that i had a hole in my
life
they would just think oh well what did
you need a father for you had a mother
but i would also say to women it's bs
that you think you can raise a child on
your own
a lot of single mothers do a very good
job of raising children
and you know often suffer a lot of
hardship but come through it anyway
but most of the time they're reliant on
the state so they might not have a
husband who
they rely on financially or for support
but instead what they do is they rely on
the state
and who is the state most funded by men
so they might not be relying on the
fathers of their children but they're
relying on other men it's a really
difficult thing to talk about because i
think
i have tremendous admiration for single
mothers in the sense that
it is incredibly difficult to bring up a
child with two parents right
you know to do it on your own is really
difficult and i have tremendous respect
for women who do that and do a good job
but
there's no denying that it's more
difficult it makes
you it makes your job more difficult as
a mother and it's more difficult for the
child
it's more difficult for them to they
need positive role models that they
don't necessarily
have as you say the evidence shows that
children with our fathers are much more
likely to to get in trouble
to go to prison etc etc but i think
there's this desire to somehow cover it
up by pretending that anyone who talks
about the need for fathers is really
just blaming the single mothers when
i i think it's much more of actually an
area where men do need to step up step
up
you know yeah and i'm not in any denial
over the fact that there are lots of
feckless fathers out there and there are
lots of men who who could step up and do
a much better job of raising their
children
but at the same time let's be honest
it's 2020 and for all the talk of
equality
fathers in this country and throughout
the west including america
do not have equal parenting rights how
can that possibly be a thing
for decades of talk about equality and
fairness and
equity fathers still don't have equal
rights
so men are expected to do 50 of the
child care
they're expected to do 50 of the
financial rearing of a child
and yet they don't have 50 rights
over that child that's absurd i mean
people wonder why fathers are
disenfranchised from the system
so you say that they don't have 50
percent of rights what does that
actually mean
peter let's break it down what does that
actually mean in legal terms
well if you're if you're a man and
you're married and
your relationship breaks down you can
essentially lose
any visitation rights to your child
overnight you might go to court spend a
small fortune on legal fees with
solicitors
you might be in mediation with your
ex-partner for months
and you can get all the course orders
you need and nobody will enforce them
yeah well we actually have a mutual
friend who essentially had to sell his
house just to be able to see his kids
right
and that happens all the time
all the time i get phone calls and
emails about it people saying what am i
going to do i'm stuck in this situation
i can no longer see my children i still
need to bankroll them i still need to
finance them and pay child support if i
don't i'll be sent to prison
but my ex-wife won't be penalized for
stopping me seeing my kids
and for me that's heartbreaking i think
that's of course yes they're refectless
for the but the
much bigger issue is the system that
excludes them
and there are a lot of people say
they're a bias you've
the the family courts are biased
particularly in the uk i can't comment
about america
but i've i know people who've been
through the family courts they say that
they're biased
would you agree with that book yeah
so you've mentioned one thing what else
how else are they biased
the family court system yeah or the
court system in general the court system
but particularly the family court system
well i mean if a father's name is not a
birth certificate
then he isn't even legally recognized as
the father anyway
so i mean that's forget whatever dna is
there forget science
we talk you've talked about science
denialism on the show before
you know that that man's dna is just
wiped from from existence in the
situation of that family
uh you know there is
even examples where men have been forced
to pay child support
for children that aren't even his i mean
only recently there was a case where
a man was forced to pay child support
for a a child who had raised for about
14 years
later transpired that the child wasn't
his the wife had lied
and the court still forced him
to pay child support wow there have been
other cases where
there was there was one situation where
a couple had gone to an ivf clinic and
he donated sperm
and during the process of the of this
they'd split up
and he had decided that he didn't want
to continue with this journey and didn't
want to have children with his partner
because they were no longer together
she forged his signature on a form got
access to the sperm was inseminated had
a child
took him to court and even though his
consent was violated
we're told about the importance of
consent all the time his consent was
violated
he was still forced to pay child support
for a child he didn't even consent to
having wow
that's terrifying and also don't give
your sperm to anyone
yeah and also you know paternity fraud
is a huge issue that is
never ever spoken about there hasn't
been a single conviction for paternity
fraud in this country
that's really interesting i mean the one
thing that again and
i i'm really glad we have you on the
show to talk about this because i think
it's really important
and to be able to talk about men and the
problems that we have
uh in this sort of unfiltered way i
think is important i really do
but i do worry with it beca and i tell
you why
um that i have this feeling like when i
when i listen to some of the way that
the in
these in-cells talk or these other there
are other groups of men who are just
bitter and resentful that's what they
are right they've checked out
they hate women many of them genuinely
hate women
they talk about them in this disgusting
disparaging ways i don't i don't i don't
like it i don't think that's the way for
for us to go
um but i just i wonder what the
constructive way to deal with it is
because
meninism will never work for men
you'll never work for us because we
don't elicit the same compassion that
women do
that's just how we're wired so talking
about
the problems of men will never work the
way feminism has worked
it just won't in this is my opinion i
think i'm right
as i always do so to me the solution is
always to get men and women back
together to the realization that we need
each other
we need to work together women we were
talking actually before the show started
and we were talking about how some
aspects of femininity are just like
magic to men we just look at and go wow
you can do that incredible you know i
remember the first time like
i saw my mum resolve an issue uh with
someone else where
my dad and i would have dealt with it
through some kind of confrontation or
aggression
and she just came and she went oh that's
so nice oh she just smiled and boom
the whole problem and i was like oh my
god you can do that you know
so so i feel like the way to deal with
this is
to sort of get men and women learning
from each other working together
realizing they need each other um do you
think
that we're sort of that's a realistic
objective at this point
well it's of course the ideal but i
don't think
it's going to happen from just having
nice fluffy conversations
yeah you know it's been a couple of
years since i wrote that book
and most of the sisterhood
just don't care you can present them
with facts they're just not interested
and i think what's happened is feminism
has become such a lucrative
industry now it's almost taken on a
different life form i think
initially it was a very noble purpose
you know there were certainly times in
history when women have been
disadvantaged they couldn't go to
university
it was only in i think the 1960s when
women couldn't get a mortgage on their
own
because they were reliant on a husband
so you know i can appreciate there have
been difficulties for them but
now as they've acquired more equality
it seems to have taken on a different
form it seems to have shape-shifted into
now almost an industry in itself a
business and it is lucrative i mean if
you look at
women's aid for example they received
last year
something like five and a half million
pounds
and nearly a million pounds of that was
from the department of
culture media and sport so just for
existing they get
i'm sure they have a lot of outgoings
but they get almost a million pounds a
year from the government
and what is a charity women's aid what
what what is women
what is women saying oh so for those who
don't know it's a it's a domestic
violence shelter
but yeah one of my issues with that is
that
of course yes anybody who suffers
domestic violence should be helped
but once again all the data shows that
most victims of domestic violence
it's almost 50 50 men and women and
women there have
actually been some studies that show
that women are actually more violent
than men although maybe
in less
damaging ways that's actually very
interesting that you bring that up
i have a friend who ended up getting
divorced because his
former wife was violent to him but it
just
it doesn't get spoken about or talked
about in the same way
as when it happens to women no it
doesn't and it also gets ridiculed
but isn't it isn't that just biology
though because men on average are bigger
and stronger and we just expect
like as you say it's less damaging so if
your wife slaps you around the face
it's not the same as a guy punching his
wife do you know what i mean well there
is an element of that
i think you're correct but at the same
time any difference in strength
is neutralized when she picks up a knife
and stabs you in the back
so it's it's really rubbish that women
can't be violent and the result
also men's hands are tied when they are
suffering from
violent women because they are
culturally taught you must never hit
a woman even in self-defense and so with
you know
jordan peterson speaks about this how do
men handle difficult women
nobody knows no men are ever taught that
francis knows just
yeah just a base shut your mouth keep
your head down don't make eye contact
exactly it's like dealing with a
velociraptor that is not going to help i
hate to break it
that's not working but going back to
your original point um before i went off
on a tangent and overthought everything
um you know yes of course getting men
and women back together and
finding solutions for these things are
great but i think it's going to have to
come the hard way
i think we're going to have to give
women uncompromising
so i think we're going to have to say
right
you want a draft for men like does the
draft for men in america and it only
applies to men
right you've got to do it for women as
well women as soon as you hit 18 you've
got to sign up for the draft
parenthood 50 50 men and women down the
middle every time
women who don't allow fathers access to
their children
you lose your passport or you lose
whatever certain freedoms that you have
you might even lose close to the other
child
i think we need to play hardball with
equality to the point where people
realize
and recognize that the genders bring
different things to the table
and perhaps we can reappreciate each
side again
so you don't actually want those
outcomes you're sort of going well if
you want to go down this is where we go
or we can go back to sensible
conversations about the fact that men
and women are different yeah you don't
actually want women to be serving in the
army
well i mean i would rather well i mean i
don't have a particular passion for
women living in the army but at the same
time i don't want
only men to be forced to serve in the
army i'd rather it just be open to
hey it's voluntary anybody who wants to
serve in the army
sign up you can do it whereas at the
moment it's only blokes who have to do
it and if they don't do it they're
denied all sorts of
federal rights and funding and all these
other things so i
i really think that the way to do it is
to kind of almost force
inconvenient equality on people and do
you not think though
what we're experiencing now is a
pendulum swinging in favor of women
where once it was in favor of men
and now because you know that they had
it hard for
centuries and now there's a little bit
of an overcorrection but eventually
it'll sort of settle in the center
and we'll all carry on as normal i love
it when people say that
people say women had it hard for
centuries i'm pretty sure
men didn't have it easy either and
if they did have it easy it wasn't
because they were men
it was because of class so if they had
it easy it's because they were middle
class
or they owned land or property and the
same applied to women
that's the biggest determiner of what
your life will be like and what we now
call privilege and it still exists today
class is the biggest determinant of how
your life will turn out
it's not a guarantee but it's a strong
determiner
not gender and so we look back
historically and say it's very difficult
for women yeah sure but it was also
really difficult for men
men who were forced to fight in the
trenches of the first world war
95 of them didn't have the right to vote
and yet middle-class women land owning
women
who sent them to war they could vote
most people don't know that fact but
it's true
it's interesting when you put it that
way you mentioned jordan peterson a few
times
and i think jordan peterson is a
fascinating
phenomenon that tells you a lot about
society and where we've come because
look
i i've always been interested in
personal development and sort of
understanding how my brain works growing
etc
so what jordan peterson was largely
saying for the last however many years
it wasn't really new to me a lot of
people who sort of
you know there wasn't really a big thing
there you know
and this is no disrespect to jordan
peterson i think he's a very courageous
individual
uh i genuinely do and i think the way he
speaks is he comes across as very
courageous very truthful
and people resonate with that but when i
watch them i was like yeah i know that
kind of thing but it had a huge impact
on the world
and do you think that and people always
made it about his largely male audience
and author do you think the response to
jordan peterson was
what it was because he was pricking
a massive bubble that existed in the
sort of
weird battle of the sexes and he was
saying no it's okay to be a man
you know you're not a bad thing because
you're male toxic masculinity is
[ __ ] or whatever it was
and he was giving men an out from that
sort of insult them
that they were being forced into some of
them absolutely people were
a hungry for truth after decades of
being gaslit by all sorts of
academics and media figures people were
hungry for
treat they still are today and he gave
them that but he also really
added a dimension of that to men who
increasingly have very little space to
exist in the world
where they're spoken to with respect or
they're spoken about with respect
or in positive ways and certainly
meaningful ways that affect their lives
and so the way that jordan peterson
resonated
so loud and for so long with so many
people including many women
i think was really testament to how big
the problem is
because jordan peterson's central
message to me from what i've seen of him
says
it's all right to be male it's all right
to want to go out and achieve things
and strive and you know and and taught
you many ways
what really your father should have
taught you discipline responsibility
all of those things yeah all of those
things tidy your bedroom
that's what your dad should have taught
you right
and yeah that was considered a really
controversial message yeah which
which i mean that is telling that such a
simple
clear obvious message was deemed
incendiary problematic misogynistic
of course none of that was the case but
if you deviate from the narrative as you
know you get kicked out of your studio
or you get cancelled or you know
whatever else happens the police come
knocking and telling you to delete
tweets that kind of thing
yeah it's really interesting uh yeah
it i one of the questions i wanted to
ask you
is do you think it's sort of getting a
bit better now and the reason i ask
this is i think if we
come back to the culture which we
started with and we look at the whole
work thing
as a package i get the sense and maybe
it's just my imagination but tell me
what you think the
the people who were sort of behind it
all or people who are running this whole
operation
they tried to split men and women
because for years there was this
massive thing going on and now i don't
really hear it as much
and maybe that's because they realize
that men and women they
men and women always you know mothers
are always going to love their boys
even if they are boys even if they have
problematic penises and whatever
you know men and women are still going
to pair up and and
procreate and have children like you
can't really split them up
and then they went oh race
that's how we separate them um
i think that's interesting i think
probably a lot of feminists are annoyed
that race is not the focal point
of the narrative i think they had it for
so long that you know they had the
spotlight for a long time
and they loved it and fair play to them
they were getting a lot of traction with
it but
um i i think there is something and
douglas more retouched on this
during your interview with him in that
it's very tempting there's something
about the human condition
something very tempting about pulling
that loose thread
and destroying the tapestry of what's
being created it may have taken
centuries to come about but it's very
tempting to destroy it
and to you know the human ego is epic
and and these people often think well i
have a better vision of how the world
should look
forget what we've known throughout
history my version of the world is going
to be better and we're all going to be
much happier
because that's really the case as we've
seen so many times throughout history
but
yeah i think maybe that maybe there is
an element of divide and conquer
with the ray suspect and um
you know it's at least they've changed
the record slightly
not in a better direction you know i
mean i can't say it's any better but at
least
at least it's slightly different for
change so where do we go from here
because it does feel like
you know the media has been there's been
a mess over correction
i mean people more and more have started
to balk at what they feel
is you know messages and slogans being
rammed down their throat so how
how do we come to a world where we're
just more pleasant to one another
and more civil i think probably one of
the
starting points would be to end the
grievant stoking
i think that is a crucial critical
fundamental first step
and perhaps that is getting rid of
defunding
if i forget defunding the police i think
we need to defund women's studies at
universities
and this this culture of teaching
young girls and and young women that
they're victims and that they should be
suspicious of men
and that they're going to go into a
workplace which is which is rigged
and stacked against them and that they
are you know
on the back foot before they've even
started in life
i understand why that happens because
for the movement to survive to be future
proof to continue
it needs new recruits and those new
recruits need to be emboldened and angry
but it causes so much unnecessary grief
a in a person's mind i i feel for a lot
of young women who are kind of gaslit by
this message that
you know that they're the victims from
the off
that's just not the case women are
thankfully
more liberated emancipated financially
independent
than they've ever been they're
completely self-determining any other
women in history would be
so envious of where most women are now
interestingly they're very unhappy but
of course they're more happy they're
more unhappy than ever
so that's what do you think that's about
do you know
well i think they've been told to
compete with men
as men perhaps prioritize the workplace
and their careers
over families and although that works
really well for some women some women
don't want children
and of course that's fine uh and they
would rather focus on their careers
i think really a lot of a lot of women
are
kind of saw the lie and and they're told
to focus and compete and
be in the office late and lean in we
hear that message all the time and then
what happens is
of course because the genders are
different women reach 40 and they
suddenly realize that oh [ __ ] i've left
it a bit too late to have children and i
know
several women who are now unfortunately
in that situation
do you think part of the problem is as
well is that this myth of you can have
it all
you can have the career the great
high-flying career
you can have the family you can have the
social life you can
look a million dollars and the reality
is look there's a finite amount of time
we can't do everything and the reality
is you've just got to pick
what you want from life i think that's
exactly right
you can have it all if you're rich
enough so if you can afford to have a
nanny
and if you can afford to have you know
someone whom it perhaps lives in and is
a maid and can do today
and help you go to work or whatever then
maybe you can have
it all but for the overwhelming majority
of people it's just not the case
and that's why the division of labour in
the home fell the way it did for so many
years
you know men would go out to the office
because it was just easier for them to
do that because they weren't
having a child and then rearing the
child
and so and so that's how families work
together and so that
that's really where it's gone wrong and
on that subject it's kind of interesting
isn't it because you mentioned it
earlier not only is there stigma
uh in certain in men doing certain
things or not doing certain things
there's actually quite a lot of stigma
against women who want to play the
traditional
role right which i find mind-boggling
like
isn't women's liberation supposed to be
about allowing women to do what they
want well you'd think
increasingly that's not the case and
often it turns out to be that
feminists want women to make choices
that are feminist
choices they don't really want to make
choices that are against the agenda
and that should raise a red flag with
anyone
because surely any movement that's about
equality and freedom and liberty just
wants people to be self-determining and
to
you know live by that classically
liberal mindset of doing whatever they
want that makes them happy
and you know all the conversation about
[ __ ] shaming and body shaming and
they're shaming all the women for the
decisions that they make about their
life i think that's sad
but even some of those concepts i mean
look at [ __ ] shame and we had megan
murphy the canadian feminist on the show
and she was saying basically like women
have been told to lie about sex which is
women can have sex the way men think
about sex and it's time to have a great
time it's not true i mean maybe some
women can do that some of the time
but by and large most of my female
friends who do that
end up conceding later on
we're just not the same i just can't
have sex like
you have sex so like all the men have
sex
and it is just a biologically different
difference and of course that is
another one of the fraudulent claims
that a lot of women
are are sold and i know that i
speak about men a lot and i defend men
and i'm compelled to do that but
you know i love women as much as i love
men i have two nieces
as well as two nephews and i'm invested
in their future and their well-being and
their happiness as well and
and so when i talk about this stuff i
really say it with women's interests
in mind as well as men's yeah it is
we do ignore biology i find it so
interesting when i have a female friend
who has a baby
just watching them completely change
their priorities change
they can be at many points you know
ferocious career driven whatever else
they have a child and immediately that
becomes their priority and you know what
they always say
best experience of my life motherhood
was the best experience of my life
loved all the jobs i had up until now
loved my high flying career in the city
but being a mother was the most
fulfilling thing i ever did
that's what i hear the most
and it's interesting because we say you
know
feminism you can do anything whatever
you want but if you saw a 21 22 year old
girl and she said you know what i just
want to get married and have babies and
have a family
and that's all i really want to do we
think that's a bit weird and that's
quite sad isn't it yeah absolutely
although i don't think many men would
have that opinion of her i think it
would be
certain types of other women who would
who would frown on her for that
and male feminist and of course male
feminists who were desperate to get laid
could be groping her when she wasn't
looking yeah as we know from left-wing
comedians
got it in this action yeah we did indeed
and then tweet about international
women's day
yeah did you follow this whole thing
that happened in the comedy world over
lockdown
basically turns out all the left-wing
comedians who've been banging on twitter
about how
we need to do this and men need to be
this and that they were
largely the ones who were getting up to
certain things behind the scenes
well imagine my shot
who'd have thought it yeah that
delightful note um
peter uh it's been great having you on i
think it's important conversation and
and
the thing that that's been the constant
like there's a bit of my head that's
constantly as we're talking going
i don't want this fight i don't want
that to be a fight i don't want men and
women to be fighting
i just don't i don't think that's
healthy helpful i don't think that's
healthy i don't think that's good for
anyone i really really don't
and if they do fight they should be
married because that's how it should do
in the privacy of their own home
yes no but i agree with you but as i
said earlier i think it's
it's slightly different for men and
their motivation
is coming from a point where they're
being defensive they have it they're
forced to defend their masculinity and
their presence in the world and their
importance
in the world because it's under attack
so i don't really see it as men and
women fighting i see it as men having to
defend
what's being attacked sure but then it's
that's still a battle isn't it that's
sure
it's not ideal but yeah but and i guess
what what you're saying is
the the people who are attacking which
is not women it's certain feminists
they need to stop attacking and then men
can stop defending and then people can
actually
have a you know healthy dialogue and
relationships right and it's not always
women who are doing the attack i always
say that there's a civil war among men
you know you have some there is on this
podcast
you have some really grim blokes out
there like
um well richard herring is one and
uh matt hague is another can't stand him
and who's that other one who used to be
in in
is it robert
oh robert robert robert
he wrote a book didn't he about how his
masculinity was dysfunctional and how
he's
realized that you know chop your dick
off robert and shut the [ __ ] up
yeah so he's written this handbook of
how men can be
less toxic there you go i've given them
advice on how he can
yeah i wouldn't normally advocate bernie
books but
that's different when you were saying
robert i kept thinking you're going to
say mcgarvey yeah
i think i'd probably rather have dinner
with robert mcgarvey
if someone did have toxic masculinity
yeah
i could buy it with robert mugabe i
think he might be up there
but um yeah i don't want that to be a
war and i think
there's got to be a way for for us to
get there you know because i
this is the other thing i mean the whole
intel thing i find
really really um
i don't know what the word is but i
don't like it i think i think it's a
problem it's a symptom of a problem
and those boys and guys who are getting
into that
i don't blame them but equally
no one's going to help them except them
they need to man up they really do
they need to you know get better they
need to
do something creative or productive get
a job whatever whatever work on
themselves go to the gym work
whatever it is they need to do better
take responsibility for their own lives
you know and i feel like that's not
happening
you know and they're being pushed into
that corner that's really not healthy
i think one of the solutions that might
happen in bringing the
the genders back together is that really
feminism
and this change in society that it's
implementing is
one great big experiment at the moment
we've never really
before done anything like what we've
done over the last 50 years
deconstructing the family and all these
other things
and so who knows where it's going to
lead if the outcome
is bad enough then maybe people will
realize
that you know like we've seen with
venezuela you know things don't always
operate as they are sold
and so i think maybe in the future
people will will look at
feminism and his historians will look at
it and say so we tried this for a
hundred years and actually
women were miserable by the end of it
and they've rejected it in favor of
balancing work and motherhood which
would be complete common sense
and the thing is as well if you're a
young man now
the truth is still the women are still
attracted to men
who are men right right like
most women like there's been all sorts
of experiments you show them a picture
of
like a guy who's built well-built and
sort of strong and masculine
versus some zoy boy they always pick the
first one yeah you know
even the woke women so for guys the best
advice really is just
to be you and not be embarrassed about
being a man and
you're probably going to be all right
right you know absolutely uh on that
happy note
uh it's been great talking to you peter
we've got one more question as always
which is
the way we end every interview which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about
that we really should be big vaginas
okay right
let's i was going to say let's elaborate
why don't we stretch the conversation
i've actually got a picture of you
by the way i've never seen our producer
look so interested in a conversation
he looks like he knows what i'm talking
about yeah of course he does yeah
you know i'm 40 years old i recently
turned 40 and i can say that throughout
most of my adult life
i have had to listen to to risery
comments
about the penis how it's not big enough
how it's not fat enough or how it's not
used properly
i'm not talking about my penis i'm
talking about all penises sure you know
penises in general are you breasts
are revered naked women are revered but
the male
appendage the penis is mocked you know
even president trump
is humiliated over allegations about his
penis
and i always think this is so unfair
when an erect penis is
you know when a man's having sex the
erect penis is not
in a vacuum it's in a vagina and if
there's dissatisfaction maybe we
need to start looking at big slack
vaginas
that's a great way to end the interview
isn't it yeah i'll be honest with you
that took a turn
i mean look no all i'm saying is if
women are happy to
to talk about men's anatomy in such a
horrid way then maybe
we should start ripping the favor and
you know just in the spirit of equality
and on that note our producer has just
crossed his legs yeah he has
and we're going to get him to insert
some crickets as we just
take a pause we'll take a pause for the
big vagina
peter thanks for coming on it's been
great to see where can people follow you
and find out what you're getting up to
so i'm probably in the process of
getting blocked on twitter
suffered gentlemen and uh
i write for lots of different sites so i
always tweet about it so
they can find me there perfect thanks
for coming on and thank you for watching
we will see you very soon
with another uh brilliant episode uh or
a live stream and all of them go out at
7pm uk
time six days a week so we'll see you
soon guys bye-bye
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word